BUCKINGHAM PALACE DENIES THAT
ALLEGATION.
>> Jesse: TRACE, THANK YOU.
HERE TO RESPOND IS RUDY
GIULIANI, PRESIDENT TRUMP'S
PERSONAL ATTORNEY AND FORMER
NEW YORK CITY MAYOR.
IT MAY OR HAVE YOU EVER BEEN TO
THIS FACILITY?
>> I WATCHED IT BEING BUILT.
>> Jesse: REALLY HOW DID THIS
HAPPEN?
I WAS AN ASSISTANT U.S. ATTORNEY
WHEN HE BUILT IT AND OCCUPIED
THE BUILDING NEXT TO IT.
IT IS CONNECTED TO THE U.S.
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE.
SO WHEN WE MOVED, I WATCHED IT
BEING BUILT AND WHEN I WAS
THERE, I HAD THE NCC, AND HAVE
BEEN IN IT 20 TIMES AS A
PROSECUTOR.
>> Jesse: I WISH SOMEONE
THOUGHT THEY WERE LOOKING OUT
THE WINDOW WHEN THIS WAS GOING
ON.
>> DON'T KNOW WHAT THEY ARE -- I
KNOW THE FLOOR THEY ARE TALKING
ABOUT.
I DON'T LIKE CONSPIRACY
THEORIES.
I DON'T THINK WE SHOULD ENGAGE
YET BECAUSE WE NEED TO KNOW THE
FACTS.
THE WHOLE THING IS COMPLETELY
INCREDIBLE TO ME.
AND I JUST SPENT THE NIGHT
HAVING DINNER WITH TWO
CORRECTIONAL OFFICIALS WHO KNOW
AND CANNOT FIGURE OUT HOW THIS
COULD HAVE POSSIBLY HAPPEN.
HOW YOU COULD LET A GUY MOST
HIGH RISK PRISONER IN THE
FACILITY WHO COULD BE KILLED FOR
SEVERAL REASONS.
HE COULD KILL HIMSELF.
>> Jesse: RATE.
>> THE PRISONERS COULD KILL THEM
BECAUSE I DON'T LIKE.
ALLEGED AND THEY DON'T LIKE
PEOPLE WHO WOULD COOPERATE.
FINALLY, THERE COULD BE PEOPLE
FROM THE OUTSIDE WHO WOULD REACH
THE PEOPLE ON THE INSIDE TO KILL
HIM.
SO YOU HAVE THREE REASONS WHY
THIS GUY SHOULD BE PROTECTED.
HE IS VIRTUALLY UNPROTECTED.
>> Jesse: SO THE
IRREGULARITIES FUELING THE
CONSPIRACY THEORY BECAUSE NOW
THERE IS A REPORT --
>> IT IS TRUE.
>> Jesse: RIGHT, WAS A REPORT
THAT THE RECORDS ARE BEING
FUDGED.
>> BUT DO YOU SUSPECT THERE
COULD HAVE BEEN FOUL PLAY?
>> IF I WERE INVESTIGATING I
WOULD HAVE TO INDULGE ALL THOSE
THEORIES.
I WOULD HAVE TO SAY HE COMMITTED
SUICIDE.
OR THEY WERE NEGLIGENT OR THEY
WERE COMPLACENT OR PRISONERS
CAME IN AND KILLED THEM AND THEY
DIDN'T REALLY CARE WHETHER THAT
HAPPENED.
SO I DON'T KNOW WHICH OF THOSE
FOUR POSSIBILITIES EXIST.
I HAVE TREMENDOUS CONFIDENCE IN
ATTORNEY GENERAL BARR COME WITH
THE FACILITY WAS NOT SOMETHING
HE WOULD HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
MANAGE IN THE SHORT TIME HE'S
BEEN THERE.
AND I REMEMBER THAT FACILITY HAS
BEEN ONE OF THE MOST SECURE
FACILITIES IN AMERICA.
I PUT MAFIA COOPERATING,
SICILIAN MAFIA COOPERATING
TERRORIST IN THERE AND NEVER HAD
A PROBLEM BECAUSE IT WAS A WELL
MANAGED.
WHAT HAPPENED TO HIM, I DO NOT
UNDERSTAND.
I WILL GIVE YOU AN EXAMPLE.
YOU PUT HIM IN A PLACE WITH A
BUNK BED.
SO WHY CAN'T YOU DO WITH A BUNK
BED?
YOU CAN TAKE A SHEET ON THE
HIGHER BUNK AND HANG YOURSELF.
HE SHOULD BE IN A FACILITY WITH
A FLATBED.
>> Jesse: RIGHT.
>> YOU CAN EASILY HANG YOURSELF.
1 OF 10 THINGS THEY DIDN'T DO.
THEY DIDN'T CHECK THE CAMERA.
APPARENTLY, THEY WERE SUPPOSED
TO CHECK ON HIM EVERY 30 MINUTES
WHICH IS KIND OF RIDICULOUS, NOT
EVERY 30 MINUTES, BUT EVEN THAT
THEY DIDN'T DO.
SO I AM, COMPLETELY PERPLEXED AS
TO WHAT HAPPENED.
>> Jesse: OKAY, LET'S MOVE ON.
WE HAVE THE MOOCH.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT HAPPENED TO
THE MOOCH.
I LOVE THE MOOCH TOO.
BUT I DON'T KNOW WHAT'S GOING ON
HERE.
>> GOING OFF OF THE RESERVATION.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Jesse: GOING OFF OF THE
RESERVATION AND WE CAN REACT TO
THAT.
>> I THINK YOU HAVE TO CONSIDER
THE CHANGE AT THE TOP OF THE
TICKET WHEN SOMEONE IS ACTING
LIKE THIS.
HE HAS A WAY TO HIS PERSONALITY.
SO THE MINUTE YOU SAY SOMETHING
HE DOESN'T LIKE, HE FIGURES THAT
HE CAN INTIMIDATE YOU LIKE A
BULLY.
THERE IS A PERNICIOUS EVIL AND
TRYING TO DIVIDE THE COUNTRY.
>> Jesse: SO HE'S NOT GETTING
AN INVITE TO THE WHITE HOUSE
THIS YEAR CHRISTMAS PARTY AT THE
WHITE HOUSE.
>> I DON'T THINK SO.
THAT IS THE WORST THING YOU CAN
DO.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT HAPPENED TO
HIM, BUT HE KNOWS
PRESIDENT TRUMP PERSONALLY.
AND I KNOW HIM PERSONALLY FOR 30
YEARS.
>> Jesse: RIGHT.
>> ONE OF THE THINGS THAT PAINS
ME IS WHAT HE HAS CHARACTERIZED.
HE IS A VERY NICE MAN.
AND I BROUGHT FIVE PEOPLE OUT TO
SEE HIM ON FRIDAY AT A
FUND-RAISER.
HE WAS SO NICE TO ME.
THEY ARE ALL TRUMP SUPPORTER'S.
THEY WALKED AWAY AND SAID, HE'S
REALLY VERY NICE.
>> Jesse: THAT'S WHAT
EVERYBODY SAYS.
>> THEY REALLY SUPPORT HIM.
WHY DO THEY THINK HE'S NICE?
LOOK WHAT HE SAID ON TELEVISION.
HE'S NOT LIKE THAT.
MOOCH KNOWS THAT.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT HE IS DOING.
>> Jesse: SO MUCH HAIR SPRAY.
MAY BE RAISING MONEY FOR THE
PRIVATE EQUITY?
GETTING A LITTLE TRUMP HATERS, I
DON'T KNOW.
>> Jesse: IT COULD BE A P.R.
MOVE BUT WE DON'T KNOW.
SPEAKING OF SOMEONE WHO NEEDS A
P.R. MOVE, JOE BIDEN APPARENTLY
IS AS EVENTFUL AS ROBERT MUELLER
THESE DAYS AND HE DIDN'T
REMEMBER THAT HE WAS ANY FUN
VICE PRESIDENT DURING THE
SHOOTING.
WATCH AS WE TALK ABOUT THEM.
[LAUGHTER]
>> I WATCHED WHAT HAPPEN WHEN
THE KIDS MARCHED UP TO HIM.
I MET WITH HIM AND HE WENT UP IN
THE HILL.
THEY WENT UP INTO THE HILL.
ALL THOSE CONGRESSMEN WERE LIKE
NO, NOT HERE, NOT HERE.
DON'T TELL HIM I'M AROUND.
THEY ARE AFRAID OF ME.
THEY SHOULD BE EXPOSED!
THEY WENT OKAY, JOE IS NOT BP
DURING THE PARK WHEN SHOOTING.
NOT A GOOD WEEK FOR JOE.
I MEAN COME I THINK HE CONFUSED
WHERE THE TWO MASS SHOOTINGS
WERE.
AND THERESA MAY WITH
MARGARET THATCHER AND THEN HE
SAID POOR KIDS --
>> VERY HARD FOR THE BIG MEDIA,
THE ONES WHO LOVE DEMOCRATS TO
GIVE UP ON JOE BECAUSE THEY
THINK HE HAS A GREAT WHITE HOPE.
AND THEY THINK HE CAN BEAT
TRUMP.
IT IS QUITE OBVIOUS THAT JOE HAS
ALWAYS DEALT WITH INTELLECTUAL
DISABILITY, LIKE HE'S NOT SMART.
SO THEY DON'T WANT TO -- THIS IS
A GUY THAT PLAGIARIZED IN
HIGH SCHOOL.
PLAGIARIZED AS A SENATOR.
BECAUSE HE CAN'T REALLY THINK
FOR HIMSELF.
OBAMA NEVER SHOULD HAVE CHOSEN
HIM AS VICE PRESIDENT BECAUSE HE
DOESN'T HAVE THE NATURAL
CAPACITY TO BE VICE PRESIDENT.
NOW, OBVIOUSLY, AND I SAY THIS
KINDLY BECAUSE OBVIOUSLY
COGNITIVE IMPAIRMENT.
>> Jesse: A COGNITIVE
IMPAIRMENT.
>> HOW DO YOU CONFUSE BEING AND
FOR ABOUT 3 MINUTES, BEING WITH
THE PARKLAND SURVIVORS AND YOU
CONFUSE THEM WITH SANDY HOOK?
WHEN DO YOU THINK IT IS A MEMORY
ISSUE?
OR DO YOU THINK SOMETHING ELSE
IS GOING ON?
>> I'VE BEEN WATCHING HIM THE
LAST THREE OR FOUR MONTHS.
SOMETHING IS WRONG.
>> Jesse: BECAUSE IT GOES TO
THE BIGGEST CONSTITUENCIES, AGE
AND MANY PEOPLE'S OPINION AND
CONFIDENCE.
>> AGENTS RELEVANT RIGHT, SO
BERNIE SANDERS COME I DON'T
AGREE WITH BERNIE SANDERS.
BERNIE SANDERS IS SHARP AS A
TECH.
>> Jesse: HIGH-ENERGY.
>> I CAME HOME FROM WASHINGTON A
COUPLE OF WEEKS AGO.
HENRY IS 90 SOMETHING.
HENRY IS STILL AS SMART AS HE
WAS 30 YEARS AGO.
SO IT'S NOT AGE, BUT SOME PEOPLE
GET, 77, SOMETHING IS GOING ON
BUT FINALLY HERE IS WHAT I'M
REALLY WORRIED ABOUT JOE.
JOE'S FAMILY FOR THE LAST 40
YEARS HAS MADE MILLIONS AND
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
OVER JOE'S PUBLIC SERVICE.
INCLUDING HIS SON WHO PULLED
DOWN MILLIONS FROM UKRAINE AND
BILLIONS FROM CHINA.
AND THE MEDIA WILL NOT COVER IT.
THEY WERE SOMETHING WRONG THERE.
IF JOE DIDN'T KNOW THAT, HE'S
EITHER DELUSIONAL OR HE'S LYING.
YOU CAN'T HAVE A SON WHO TOOK
DOWN A BILLION DOLLAR INVESTMENT
FROM CHINA WHEN YOU WERE
NEGOTIATING WITH CHINA AND YOU
DIDN'T KNOW ABOUT IT.
PARTICULARLY A SON YOU ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT AS HE GOT THROWN
OUT OF THE MILITARY FOR FAILING
A COCAINE TEST.
>> Jesse: I DON'T KNOW WHAT IS
WORSE, NOT KNOWING WHAT IS GOING
ON AROUND YOU AND KNOWING AND
NOT DOING ANYTHING ABOUT IT.
>> MY TAKE ON JOE HAS ALWAYS
BEEN, NOT VERY SMART, NICE GUY
AND NOW I HAVE A THIRD ONE.
HE MAY NOT BE TOTALLY STRAIGHT.
THE FAMILY MADE TOO MUCH MONEY
AND THAT OFFENDS ME.
>> Jesse: CRICKET JOE?
>> I DON'T KNOW.
EITHER CROOKED JOE OR JOE DIDN'T
KNOW.
>> THE BROTHER MADE MILLIONS
COME WITH THE SUN MADE MILLIONS
AND THEY WERE TRADING UNDER
PUBLIC OFFICE.
>> THERE IT IS.
YOU KNOW, BEATING THE DRUM FOR
IMPEACHMENT FOR I THINK SENSE
THE PRESIDENT WAS INAUGURATED.
HE HAS COME OUT WITH THIS NEW
TAKE ON IMPEACHMENT THAT
INVOLVES ELECTION STRATEGY.
LISTEN TO THIS.
>> IF HE HAS NOT DEFEATED IN THE
SENATE, HE WILL STILL RUN AS AN
IMPEACHED PRESIDENT AND THERE
WILL BE A GOOD MANY PEOPLE WHO
WON'T WANT TO HOLD FUND-RAISERS
WITH HIM.
A GOOD MANY PEOPLE WHO WON'T
WANT TO BE IN HIS COMPANY
BECAUSE A GOOD MANY OF THESE
WEALTHY PEOPLE WHO ARE
BENEFITING FROM HIS BIGOTRY.
>> Jesse: SO THIS IS AN ABOUT
CHECKS AND BALANCES.
THIS IS AN ABOUT MISDEMEANORS.
THIS IS ABOUT BRANDING THE
PRESIDENT, DRIVING HIS NUMBERS
DOWN AND INTIMIDATING DONORS AND
VOTERS INTO SUPPORTING HIM.
>> WELL, I THINK THAT THESE
DEMOCRATS WERE DOING THIS, I
THINK THEY NEED THERAPY.
>> Jesse: TRUMP DERANGEMENT
KICKING AND?
>> NOW IS A KIND OF MENTAL
ILLNESS.
A LOT OF PSYCHIATRIST IN
NEW YORK, MORE PSYCHIATRIST ANY
PLACE ELSE.
I WOULD SUGGEST THEY GO TO THE
PSYCHIATRIST, GET HELP.
HE'S BEEN CLEAR THREE TIMES.
HE'S MY CLIENT.
AS IF I HAVE A CLIENT CLEARED
THREE TIMES.
ONCE IS USUALLY ENOUGH.
TWICE AS RIDICULOUS, THREE
TIMES?
HE DIDN'T COLLUDE WITH THE
RUSSIANS.
HE DIDN'T OBSTRUCT JUSTICE.
GET OVER IT.
SO GO AFTER HIM ON IMMIGRATION.
GO ON -- AFTER HIM ON TAXES, THI
GO ON -- AFTER HIM ON TAXES, THS
RIDICULOUS.
AND IT'S ONLY BECAUSE
IMMEDIATELY SO SET AGAINST HIM
THAT THEY EVEN TOLERATE THIS.
>> Jesse: WELL, THEY KNOW
WHAT'S GOING NOWHERE IN THE
SENATE.
THEY KNOW THE MAJORITY OF THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE DON'T SUPPORT
IMPEACHMENT.
SO THEY JUST WANT TO HURT HIM IN
THE HOUSE SO PEOPLE THINK, OH,
WOW, WHO ARE PAYING ATTENTION
THIS GUY WAS IMPEACHED.
MAYBE I SHOULDN'T THROW HIM A
FUND-RAISER.
>> POLITICALLY, I BELIEVE IT
WILL BACKFIRE.
>> Jesse: WHY IS THAT?
>> I THINK THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
HAVE HAD ENOUGH OF IT.
AFTER THE MUELLER PERFORMANCE A
COUPLE OF WEEKS AGO.
THE CLEARING OF HIM ON BOTH
COLLUSION AND THEN MUELLER HAD
TO COME OUT AND SAY BASICALLY,
HE COULDN'T FIND OBSTRUCTION
AFTER KIND OF, HE LIED OR
WHATEVER, HE CAME OUT AND
CORRECTED IT AND NEVER FOUND
OBSTRUCTION.
WHAT ARE THEY DOING?
AND THEN HE WAS CLEARED EARLIER
IN THE SEVEN-MONTH
COUNTERINTELLIGENCE PROBE OF
COLLUSION.
SO I THINK THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
HAVE HAD ENOUGH OF IT.
POLITICALLY, IT WILL HELP THE
PRESIDENT IF THEY CONTINUE
IMPEACHMENT.
I THINK NANCY PELOSI WILL LOSE
THE 40 SEEDS IN THE REPUBLICAN
DISTRICTS WHERE HER PEOPLE ONE.
SHE KNOWS THAT.
THAT IS WHY SHE WHO RETAINS A
CERTAIN AMOUNT OF ADULT MATURITY
UNDERSTANDS.
BUT I'M NOT SURE SHE CAN CONTROL
JERRY NADLER.
JERRY WANTS TO BE ON DAYTIME
TELEVISION WITH HIS MAKEUP ON.
BUT I ACTUALLY THINK --
>> Jesse: WE DON'T HAVE ANY
MAKEUP.
>> IT'S GOING TO GO NOWHERE.
>> Jesse: NANCY IS ONLY ONE
THAT DOESN'T HAVE TRUMP
DERANGEMENT?
>> I THINK NANCY IS A PRACTICAL
POLITICIAN.
WHATEVER YOU THINK OF HER AND I
DON'T AGREE WITH HER POLITICAL
THAT SHE IS A SMART POLITICIAN.
SHE KNOWS THIS IS A LOSING
STRATEGY.
SHE IS TRYING HARD TO TAKE THE
CRAZIES DOWN.
AND I THINK IT WILL WORK
EVENTUALLY.
I DON'T THINK WE HAVE TO WORRY
ABOUT IT.
>> Jesse: BE FIVE SAYS
NANCY PELOSI IS THE VOICE OF
REASON AND THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
>> I NEVER THOUGHT I WOULD SAY
THAT.
I CAMPAIGNED AGAINST HER SO